hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is uh Sunday January 8th 2023 and
you know I was just going through some
of my emails and you know sort of a
recurring question that I get probably
asked weekly is what is the best chart
type to trade order flow with
so you know that's what's going to be
the topic of this video now again you
know before I dive into it um if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe to
the channel and find you get something
out of this video be sure to hit the
like button so what is the best chart
type for trading order flow I think if
you were to ask 10 different people you
would get 10 different answers but
really what you want to get out of your
chart type because choosing your chart
type is really a personal matter and you
want to get insight into the order flow
from your chart that is making it easy
for you to observe price movements now
what I'm going to talk about today the
chart types are the most common ones
that I use for order flow analysis and
that's the time based chart a range base
chart uh tick based chart and volume
based chart I don't use a renko based
chart for order flow
um
people ask what about things like hike
and Ashi yeah you could use hikanashi
um you could use point and figure
although the
ninjatrader point and figure capability
leaves a lot to be desired and you know
other things like line break you're not
going to use order flow with so let's
just sort of take a look at the main
charts now you know the thing about
order flow right is you're really
looking at the information
when it is most fresh meaning
um you know you want to get your insight
into what the big players are doing as
soon as possible so again you know I'm
not necessarily a big fan of looking at
30 minute charts in the order flow you
can I know some people that do that they
they want to get you know they're
looking very very specific things on a
30 minute chart they're not looking at a
lot of different things you're looking
for like very specific instances
but I'll save that for another video but
really like for me what I'm looking for
is you know getting me as close to
what's happening in the market in terms
of what's trading on the bid and and the
offer right I want to use this
information as soon as as soon as is
available basically I want to take
advantage of you know things happening
in the order flow
as soon as it's printing basically if
there's something to be had so first
we'll start off with an eight range
chart I want people you know sometimes
people get all caught up in trying to
search for the perfect chart type
without even realizing they're sort of
looking at the same chart and
you know people that you know traders
that I've talked to that say oh I I
don't want to use a time-based charge
because I don't want to be constricted
by time and all of a sudden then they're
using a you know essentially like a 10
range chart in the e-minis which
basically acts as almost a a one minute
chart in most cases or depending on on
you know what range you're using you
know they'll say oh because you know I
like to use a 30 second chart
on the S PS and why do you trade such a
short-term chart then they go with a
five range chart you know which is
much faster than a 30 second chart so
first we'll start with this eight range
and this is just a quick chart from
what was this Friday afternoon you know
right around you know the 215 time zone
time period where you know we did make
those new highs and let's just sort of
take a look so you can see here at 2 17
17. now again this is an eight range
chart you know I know some people that
use five range I know some people that
use 10 range I've always used an eight
range I have tried looking at a 10 range
but you know eight ranges is good enough
for me
and you know we have that high showing
up there but what's interesting is
You'll See This Bar forms well we'll
start here 14 15 and 50 seconds then the
next bar is 14 17 17 seconds so about a
minute and a half then the next Bar 14
18 17. so about a minute there then the
next bar about a minute later next bar
about a minute later next bar about a
minute later right so on on an eight
range you're rough you know roughly
speaking it's about a minute to a minute
and a half per bar and if you're looking
at a where's my minute page chart right
this is my minute base chart
you know it's it's clear it's a
minute-based chart it's it's every one
minute and so like for example at the
high that was formed at 14 16 on the
minute base chart on the Range base
chart you have a Divergence you don't
have that appearing on the minute base
chart okay
so even though you know the order flow
essentially I mean obviously the trades
that are going through is the same the
way it's appearing on the chart you're
getting different sort of views as to
what's happening in the market which
one's better well it really depends on
what you want to look for in the order
flow because once the market starts
moving quickly you know on your range
base chart
you're gonna get
a lot of bars really quick that on the
one minute chart it's just going to be
one bar now if you go to something like
a volume based chart this is a 5000
volume based chart now
on a one minute chart I could see that
you know volumes aren't anywhere between
you know two and a half thousand to four
thousand
sometimes you get up you know even that
you get more you get six thousand you
know and you can get a lot more
sometimes so you know but basically
between two and a half to five thousand
yeah on a minute base chart okay so if
I'm looking at a volume based chart if
I'm looking at a 5 000 volume chart you
know it's going to be about one minute
uh you know about two minutes I'd say
more like a minute and a half to two
minutes uh per bar so you know there are
these time I mean of course there's
gonna be times where you just get a ton
of volume that come through and it's
going to be you know maybe one or two
bars in in a minute but those are pretty
rare but generally this one's moving
more like a two minute bar chart right
so you you gotta understand the market
that you're trading you think well I'm
gonna use a 5 000 volume chart and it's
gonna do away with time because I'm just
looking at volume well
Market trades right it trades volume and
what you're looking at I mean you know
if you follow the time based chart you
know it generally trades about on
average maybe two and a half to three
thousand per minute so
that you could make the educated guess
of saying well five thousand volume
chart is going to be about you know a
minute and a half to two minutes okay
that's not complicated
um when you get to some slightly
different charts is you know a tick base
chart where's my tick base chart here
all right so this is a 1000 tick chart
okay
fine fair enough and you know again
tick based chart is based on each trade
that goes through whether it's one
contract or whether it's a thousand
contracts that is one tick so
with s PS you know the The Exchange they
put out the information every once in a
while I don't know how often but I do
come across it every every so often the
average trade size in the S PS is like
1.6 contracts
of course you know it's it's an average
size because there's a lot of people
that trade one Lots in there right which
sort of brings down the average and you
got the guys that trade 10 50 100 at a
time
and obviously you got all those
execution how it goes It's All About You
Know One lot here one lot there
but just really briefly if you're
looking at you know the 1000 tick chart
again it's about you know here you got
you just take the time you just look at
it right 14 12 57 14 13 14 seconds so
this is about 15 seconds and then to the
next bar it's about 30 seconds
next bar again it's about 40 seconds
this one you know again about 40 seconds
then here's about 40 seconds so it's
around less than a minute more than 30
seconds so somewhere in there you could
sort of guesstimate on sort of the time
and again you know I talk to people well
I'm using a tick chart I don't use time
okay well what what's your tick chart
okay what are you moving you're using a
very fast chart base now it doesn't
matter which one you're using what
matters is
how easy is it for you to understand
what you're seeing in the order flow and
again you know one of the reasons why I
do use time based charts and tick based
charts
and even range based charts is sometimes
I'm going to see something in the order
flow that I probably might not see
on a different chart okay so and this is
a perfect example right we came up to
this high of the day here and again this
is sort of like setup that I like to
look at you know so we're going up into
the high Delta's declining then it turns
sharply negative as it turns sharply
negative I have you know the point of
control way up here on this red candle
at the top
in the next bar it's just it's all
selling basically the Delta was minus
416. the Min Delta is minus 417 so we're
closing almost on our Min Delta I got a
nice stack selling a balance coming in
here and you know it just looks very
bearish on a tick based chart whereas
on a
range based chart
okay what do I have well yeah I've got
here it's sort of like Delta is looking
like it's increasing 365 377 400 then
it's you know sharply negative minus 229
minus 551. I don't have the Stacked
imbalance this stacked in Balance
interestingly enough is split up between
this bar and this bar these two bars the
point of control is somewhere in the
middle I do have a Delta Divergence okay
that's nice so what looks
very bearish here on the 1000 tick chart
you've got bearish signal but it's kind
of a different bearish signal okay I
mean the way the Delta is shaping up
going into the high is different but
after the high you see the the sharp
selling taking place in terms of the
Deltas in here obviously you don't have
that stacked imbalance in this bar after
the high is made
now on a Time based chart
you don't have the Divergence
the Delta is kind of mixed going up
right it's 545 249 395 so it's big
medium bigger again then again it's
negative more negative okay fine I've
got nice stacks on a balance here I got
a couple of zero prints in there
um you know I don't have that Divergence
that's taking place on the Range based
chart
you know it just it looks different now
that's not to say that
you can't take a trade but if you're
looking if you have sort of these three
different charts opening
or open up again you don't have to keep
flipping your charts you know just buy
another monitor and split it up you know
you could have
um
you know you just put four different
Footprints up here you put you know your
your range base your time based your
volume based and and you know whatever
you want right I mean you could
literally buy I I you could buy like 27
inch monitors around 120 bucks now I
think let's go to Costco there he's got
sales going on in these things or Best
Buy
just to have that up there because maybe
you might see something
manifesting on a 1000 tick chart that
you're not seeing on your range base
chart or your time based charts if
you're just looking at a time-based
chart then you're probably going to miss
this short opportunity which was
probably very obvious here on the tick
chart very obvious on the Range base
chart and again you know if you're
looking at a volume based chart there's
nothing right there's nothing really
telling you to get short up in here off
this high
all right so again you know if you limit
yourself to one chart type then you know
sometimes you're going to find yourself
missing opportunities in the same Market
I mean and that's fine all right I mean
opportunities come around all day long
right it's not like someone's got a gun
to your head and say you gotta you gotta
pull the trigger you got to take a trade
but
having just that extra chart up there
maybe you can see something
in the chart it's going to give you an
insight into the market
specifically the order flow that you
might not have seen otherwise right I
mean sometimes things stand out more
when you just look at it a bit different
all right this way you know if you ever
you know you go to you know a museum and
you look at the rocks or the gem
collection it's not you know they they
put the the most beautiful piece you
know it's a standalone in the middle you
could walk around it you know you could
see it from all angles sometimes the
same thing with the market right just
looking at it from a different angle is
going to give you help you see something
that you might not have seen else wise
and again I don't recommend like during
the trading session just keep flipping
around your charts no just keep them
open you could even have them you know
on different tabs I like to use the tabs
on here as well but I also I have a lot
of screens no I'm not one of these guys
where my whole wall of screens but
you know if you're if you're trading
just you know one market it's going to
be who view it's going to be in your
best interest to have you know a tick
based chart a volume based chart a
time-based chart
and
you know an arrange based chart just
don't don't put yourself into the corner
because you might not see something
that's that's so obvious there and again
you know it's choosing the right chart
type is
you know a very personal decision
because it's going to be based on your
your risk tolerance
and you know you're you know your risk
tolerance is one but what I'm saying is
like your your heart attack tolerance
right because if you go too fast and
you've got to make decisions really
quick for some people they can't handle
that right nobody wants to be trading
under the gun so to speak so
you know what I would say is you know if
if you're struggling to find your right
chart type put up different charts
during the day keep them side by side
and watch them
see which makes it easier for you to
understand the order flow
because you know at the end of the day
it's pointless to have
you know order watch the order flow if
you can't make heads or tails of it and
oftentimes there is a chart type that is
going to help you understand the order
flow much better than others for example
right if
you watch order flow on a volume based
chart but you're not seeing anything
well move away from that volume based
chart try a range based chart you know
try a Time based chart okay it's all
about finding the chart that helps you
maximize what you're looking at in the
order flow
so again you know I hope this video
didn't confuse you even more about chart
types but again you know it's an
important part of trading having the
right chart
because at the end of the day you know
that's what's going to help you make the
money so you want to be looking at
something that is easy for you to read
easy for you to understand and can make
decisions based off of
so anyway guys I hope you got something
useful out of this video and I'll catch
you guys on the next video bye bye